right
and it's a sobering thought that the
consequences of what happened then may
be continuing to cause death even now
many inquiries are about events which
have happened where there it is known
exactly how many people may have died
few if any this may be the first where
deaths are continuing to happen so you
understand why I say in that sense I
cannot be glad that you're here at all
there what I do welcome is that by sheer
numbers you are drawing attention to the
importance of this inquiry I know
because you've told me that some of you
who've been infected or affected by the
illness of someone dear to you have felt
that not enough attention has been given
in the media to these serious issues to
be investigated the sound of silence if
you like and so I can also welcome the
fact that both the written and the
televisual press are here in numbers to
give some of that attention and I hope
that as the inquiry progresses they will
do what they do best
and report it both fearlessly and fairly
also before I turn to the purposes of
these days of preliminary hearings I'd
like to say thank you thank you that is
to all of you who spoke to me during the
consultation period and who helped to
shape the terms of reference in your
different ways from your different
backgrounds from your different
perspectives and with stories to tell
which were all individual you have
already taught me a lot a lot I had not
previously appreciated
and I hope that you will continue to do
just that whether the inquiry succeeds
in answering its terms of reference
depends very much on you
I know because a woman who lost her son
specifically asked a member of the
enquiry staff last week to remind me of
it that for some the very fact of the
enquiry will reopen old wounds which
makes it all the more difficult to bring
themselves to play a part and yet they
nonetheless wish to do so I recognize
that bravery which makes their
contributions all the more valuable what
is the purpose of the preliminary
hearings over these next three days as
the word preliminary suggests the
inquiry is not taking evidence it's not
hearing the stories of those who want to
tell them during the two-and-a-half days
to follow so what is the purpose we're
just as I have already learned a lot by
listening and thinking about some of the
accounts given to me during the
consultation period I'm here to listen
and I want to know in particular two
things from the core participants first
to know what aspect of the terms of
reference each wishes to emphasize and
concentrate on and secondly how they can
best help to shape the inquiries
procedures to address the mammoth task
which it has set itself so that's its
purpose I want to listen to what you
have to say rather than to express any
view which I may have indeed how could I
have an answer to any of the terms of
reference without first considering all
the evidence and we're still very much
in the early stages of gathering Eddie
though there has been quite a lot
received so far counselor to the inquiry
Jenny Richards Queen's Counsel will have
more to say about that in a few minutes
time she'll tell you a lot of the detail
of what has happened what is being done
at the moment what is yet to be done and
what you can expect to happen I'm happy
for now to leave that detail to her what
I do want to say something about the way
I intend this inquiry to be conducted I
am determined that the process of this
inquiry should be governed by principle
with an inquiry of this magnitude the
principles that will need to guide it
have to be very clear so let me tell you
what they are the first is that I want
to put people at the heart of this
inquiry now that's not just a slogan I
mean it it has at least at least three
practical consequences one the first
three months of oral hearings will be
taken up by hearing from some of those
who've been infected and some of those
close to them parents family friends
colleagues carers who have been affected
the infected and affected thirst but
also last at the end of the oral
hearings there will be a further
opportunity for some we could not hear
in the first few months so the infected
and affected first and last two
the hearings will not be in a courtroom
they won't be here but they will not be
in a courtroom
this is an inquiry it's not a court case
and much as I welcome legal
representatives and I do it's not a
trial whatever it may lead to later and
it's not run for the benefit of lawyers
but for people who are involved so the
hearing room will be designed so that
there won't be racks of lawyers and the
front row obscuring the view of the
public who needs to hear the people
who've been infected affected those
concerned those touched by the inquiry
my aim is to have lawyers to one side
press to the other and members of the
public in front of the witness who would
take center stage as the witness should
the judge went there isn't a judge it's
not an inquiry three the inquiry
recognizes how difficult it is for some
to relive matters they would want to put
behind them maybe traumatic and so we
intend to have a counseling service or
support service available for those who
want it and to do our best in how we
proceed to be sensitive to the way in
which individuals are feeling putting
people at the heart of this inquiry also
leads to the next three principles the
longer the inquiry takes the more will
not live to see its consequences the
longer some may suffer the significant
anxieties of waiting for its conclusions
let me tell you when we were consulting
about the terms of reference I confess
that the inquiry made something of a
mistake it asked what the time period
was that the inquiry should cover
what it meant well should it be the time
period between 1974 to 1999 81 294 84
1981 thereafter whatever the years might
have been but the question has put was a
bit clumsy and unclear at a large number
of respondents understood it to be
meeting how long should the inquiry
itself last there was a strong view for
reasons which are sadly obvious that it
should be quick now putting people at
the heart of the inquiry whether those
people seek to attribute blame or seek
to evade it or simply want answers means
listening to what's being said the
question may have been badly drafted but
the answer coming back was clear about
the time the inquiry should last it was
there to be heard and it was it's led to
the principle that the inquiry should be
as fast as reasonable thoroughness will
permit putting people at the heart of
the inquiry must recognize that people
have different perspectives to bring to
the inquiry you saw some of them this
morning reflected in what that those who
were recorded were saying to you the
perspectives go wider than that it
cannot just be a favored few or even a
favored many who are at its heart those
who wish to attribute blame those
seeking to escape blame those who wish
neither but just seek to understand what
happened and why it happened or to
explain their actions why they did what
they did those who are him effects those
who were transfused with infected blood
or those who were both
those who were patients or those who are
doctors all our people all are entitled
to be heard and I'd ask all participants
to respect that entitlement
however unpalatable they may find some
of the ideas or explanations or
accusations or assertions being put
forward the principle is to give proper
respect to a person's entitlement to be
heard putting people at the heart of the
inquiry means to that it will hear
infected and affected individuals across
the country the inquiry will not confine
itself to London it is uk-wide it will
be UK wide and it will conduct some of
its hearings in Edinburgh in Belfast in
Cardiff and in the north of England
probably in leaves that should enable
more people to come in and hear its
proceedings firsthand if they should
wish though they will of course be
live-streaming to those then are the
principles by which this inquiry will
operate but let me be also with this but
I am determined so far as it is open to
me to ensure that the work which has to
be done by representatives to enable
those infected and affected to play a
meaningful part in the inquiry will be
properly funded for the heart of the
inquiry properly to beat no less is
required
I want this inquiry to be as open and
transparent as it is legally possible to
be there's navigation of cover up to be
investigated so how could the inquiry
itself hide something from you and keep
any integrity you will see the evidence
you will read or hear the evidence which
our experts are giving to me and just
look at the range of experts at the
range and number of experts who are
willing to give their time to help so
far they're true leaders in their fields
and there are more yet to be appointed
the documents which the inquiry sees as
relevant will all be available to core
participants I mentioned the allegation
of cover-up you should know that it is
not only the law but a central principle
of mine that this inquiry is independent
of government it I am willing to seek
documents which may not have been seen
before we have already requested a
number of documents which we would not
have got had this not been a statutory
inquiry it is willing to hold people to
account where appropriate and it will
express its views at the end without
fear or favour affection or ill-will the
principles the inquiry will people at
his heart uk-wide it will be as fast as
reasonable thoroughness will permit it
will pay proper respect to persons
entitlements to be heard it will be as
open and transparent as it is legally
possible to be it will be independent of
government and frightened of no one in
the conclusions it draws but there is
one final principle which I haven't yet
mentioned except in passing it is that
the inquiry will listen to what is being
said to it orally or in writing and it
will think about what is being said and
it brings me back to these preliminary
hearings I don't for the next two days
to listen to what you will call
participants have to tell me is your
particular
from within the terms of reference and
to hear how you think you can best help
shape the inquiries procedures to
address the task it has been set the
inquiry involves afterall a collective
effort by all participants by you by me
by the inquiry team by the experts
working together listening well thank
you for your part for listening to me
now I've set out the principles and I
shall now pass the baton over to Council
to the inquiry Jenni Richards QC to tell
you more of the detail of what has been
what is and what is yet to be and I hope
you'll listen to her as you have
listened to me
and thank you again for that
[Applause]
[Applause]
good afternoon the purpose of my
statement today is to provide
information about the workings of the
inquiry in particular to give an update
on its work so far and to map out where
the inquiry proposes to go from here I
do not propose at this stage to talk
about the events which bring us here nor
could I hope to match the eloquence and
power of those whose voices were heard
this morning I want to start by saying a
little about the inquiries terms of
reference the terms of reference for a
public inquiry describe the matters
which the inquiry is permitted to
investigate an inquiry cannot begin
considering evidence until its terms of
reference are established that is not a
choice for the inquiry that is the
effect of the inquiries act this
inquiries terms of reference were
approved by the minister as the Act
requires them to be but they were
approved in the form recommended by the
chair with no alterations and they were
published on the second of July of this
year they were as many of you known as
the chair has referred to the product of
a public consultation to which many
individuals and others contributed I
think I speak for the whole inquiry team
when I say that all those involved in
the consultation process found it moving
humbling and enlightening to listen to
what was said and those contributions
informed and shaped those terms of
reference now the terms of reference
have been widely publicized and they
appear on the inquiries website and I
know that many here have read and reread
them I don't propose to read them out
but for the benefit of those listening
those watching elsewhere who are not
familiar with the terms of reference
I'm just going to set out briefly the
six key themes or areas that they cover
firstly the terms of reference require
us to look at what happened and why it
will involve an examination of the
circumstances in which men women and
children treated by the National Health
Services in the four parts of the United
Kingdom were given infected blood and
infected blood products it will look at
what was known about the risks by the
medical and scientific community it will
look at issues such as self-sufficiency
in blood and blood products the second
area for theme for the terms of
reference will seek to establish the
scale of what happened to ascertain as
far as practicable the true numbers of
people infected in consequence of the
use of infected blood products or
infected blood and to examine whether
people may have been exposed to the risk
of other viruses the third theme of the
terms of reference are the questions of
impact and support the inquiry will look
at the impact in all respects on those
infected and affected the mental and
emotional impact the physical and
medical impact Social Work related
financial the strain for many as we
heard this morning of living lives in
secret for many years and the inquiry in
this part of its work will scrutinize
for support that has or has not been
made available both in terms of
treatment and care and in terms of
financial support the fourth theme of
the inquiries terms of reference is to
explore key ethical issues around
consent communication
and information-sharing in that part of
the inquiries work we will look at
matters such as what information was
provided to people about the risks
diagnosis and treatment options how such
information was communicated whether
people were treated or tested without
their knowledge or consent or for the
purposes of research or otherwise the
fifth area of the inquiries work will be
to look at response of government of the
national health services and others the
medical profession and the like and the
six will be to examine whether there has
been as many alleged a cover-up or a
lack of candor and openness those are by
way of broad outline the areas which the
inquiry is investigating the inquiry is
empowered by its term of references to
term of reference to look at individual
responsibilities as well as
organizational and systemic
responsibilities to look at whether
there are lessons that can be learned
for the future and to make
recommendations the terms of reference
have been crafted in broad but
comprehensive terms to allow the inquiry
to pursue the lines of investigation
identified by so many of you in
responding to the consultation in due
course we will set out and publish as is
the practice for public statutory
inquiries a more in-depth and detailed
list of the specific issues on which the
inquiry is focusing within each of the
terms of reference that list will be
informed by what we hear over the next
two days about the priorities of core
participants and when published it will
remain a living and evolving document we
expect that core participants and others
will have plenty of suggestions to make
by way of additions to that list of
issues and that the inquiry itself will
continue to identify new lines of
Investigation as it analyzes the
evidence which it receives
before we describe some of the steps
which the inquiry has taken since its
formal establishment on the 2nd of July
of this year I want to say a few words
about scale the inquiry does not
underestimate the scale of the task
which it faces it recognizes that this
is an immense undertaking which will
require an enormous amount of work it is
immense because of the breadth of the
issues which are encompassed within the
terms of reference it is immense because
of the periods of time which are under
investigation this enquiry is looking
not at events which unfolded over
minutes hours days weeks or even months
but at actions and inaction conduct
decision-making policymaking over
decades
indeed whilst the terms of reference
take 1970 onwards as their particular
focus the inquiry is already asking for
and looking at material dating back to
the inception of the National Health
Service in 1948 the scale of a task is
immense too because of the volume of
material documentary material which the
inquiry is likely to receive and which
will run no doubt to hundreds of
thousands of documents and most
importantly the scale of the task is
immense because of the sheer numbers of
people already known to have been
infected and affected the thousands of
lives lost or irrevocably damaged or
overshadowed by what has happened since
the inquiry was formally established on
the second of July one of its earliest
tasks has been the determination of
applications for core participant status
this inquiry has to the best of our
knowledge the largest number of core
participants of any public inquiry
there are currently 1280
eight core participants of which the
vast majority are infected and affected
individuals 1272 those core participants
will have a significant role to play in
shaping the work of the inquiry but we
recognize of course that there are many
infected and affected individuals who
are not core participants and it is very
important for us to emphasize that this
does not mean that their evidence is of
any lesser value to the inquiry in
addition to the individuals there are
currently eight charities or campaigning
organizations who are core participants
the Scottish infected blood forum
haemophilia Scotland haemophilia
Northern Ireland haemophilia Wales the
haemophilia society the UK thalassemia
Society the hepatitis C trust and factor
eight we anticipate that there are
likely to be further applications by
other campaigning organisations with
charities three government departments
are called participants the Department
of Health and Social Care for England
the Department of Health Northern
Ireland and the Health and Social
Services group of the Welsh Government
you will hear brief opening statements
on behalf of each of those on Wednesday
you will notice that I have not
mentioned the Scottish Government's
Department of Health the Scottish
Government's Health and Social Care
Directorate is not currently at least a
core participant and I should for the
benefit of the many affected and
infected individuals from Scotland who
are participating in this inquiry
explain why we understand that to be the
case we understand that the Scottish
government's current position is that it
will not apply to be a core participant
because it considers that the inquiry
should not insofar as Scotland is
concerned revisit issues already
considered by the penrose inquiry that
is not the view of this inquiry nor does
it accurately reflect
to the terms of reference which were the
subject of extensive consultation
including in Scotland whilst this
inquiry will of course avoid unnecessary
duplication of work done by the Penrose
inquiry the terms of reference which it
must deliver clearly applies as much to
Scotland as it does to Northern Ireland
Wales and England it is the matter of
regret to the inquiry that the Scottish
government has taken this position but
we can assure all concerned that this
does not affect the inquiries powers
visibly the Scottish government at all
the inquiry can and will indeed already
has exercised its powers under the
enquiry rules to request the Scottish
government to provide the documents and
other information which the inquiry
requires whether or not it becomes a
core participant likewise the chair can
and if necessary will exercise his power
under Section 21 of the Inquirer's Act
to order the production of documents and
material irrespective of core
participant status I should in fairness
add that in any event we have no reason
to believe that the Scottish government
will not voluntarily provide that which
we ask of it before national blood
transfusion services are also called
participants NHS blood and transport in
England the Scottish national blood
national blood transfusion service the
Welsh Blood Service and the Northern
Ireland blood transfusion service and
the Regional Health and Social Care
board for Northern Ireland which was the
successor body to the board responsible
for Northern Ireland's blood transfusion
service until 1994 it is we think very
likely that the numbers of core
participants will continue to grow in
particular we are giving careful
consideration as to how best to ensure
the participation in the acquiring of
other NHS bodies such as the trusts and
boards responsible for the many
haemophilia centres across the United
Kingdom the conduct and decisions of
whose former employees will be a central
part of the inquiries
were the inquiries investigative work
has begun in earnest but there is very
much more to do there have been two
principal focuses for the inquiries
investigative work so far firstly
obtaining witness statements from
infected and affected people and
secondly seeking the disclosure of
relevant documents from governmental and
public bodies and other relevant sources
I shall deal with each intern gathering
witness statements from individuals who
are infected or affected is a priority
for the inquiries work for two reasons
firstly the poor and deteriorating
health of a number of them means we want
to receive as many witness statements
early in the inquiry as we can
secondly as the chair has explained the
experiences of infected and affected
people the accounts they have to give
lie at the heart of this inquiry on the
2nd of July immediately upon being set
up the inquiry invited people who were
infected or affected in consequence of
infected blood products or blood to
complete a short form telling the
inquiry whether and if so how they would
like to give evidence we received over
1,300 such forms and since then many
further individuals have come forward
and we expect currently in the region of
about 2,200 odd statements from infected
or affected people but over the coming
months the inquiry has begun the process
of obtaining witness statements so far
in terms of the enquiry zone work is
concerned it's identified around 650
individuals from whom the inquiry team
itself will be taking statements you do
not need legal representation in order
to provide evidence to the inquiry and
individuals who feel able to can draft
their own statements or really enquiry
will assist with the preparation of the
statement for everyone who wants to help
but for the many individuals who are
legally represented we will be asking
there
legal representatives to obtain those
statements and we will be finding the
costs of so doing this is a process that
will continue over the coming months the
focus of these statements will be the
individual personal experiences of those
who were infected and the individual
personal experiences of their families
and loved ones we understand that it
will not be an easy task but a number of
those who will be giving statements are
in poor health and that they are being
asked to tell us about highly personal
and distressing matters
I should also make clear that before any
witness statement is disclosed ie made
available to call participants or is
published on the enquiry website
individuals who are infected or affected
will be able to ask the inquiry not to
disclose or publish their name or not to
disclose or publish particular
information within their statement and
where a witness who is infected or
affected requests anonymity it is likely
that the chair will grant that request
in light of the fact that so many of
these statements will contain highly
sensitive and personal medical
information there is a lot more
information about this process published
on the inquiries website in its
statement of approach the inquiry has
asked and obtained the agreement of the
heads of the health service in England
Northern Ireland Scotland and Wales to
waive the fees that might otherwise be
charged for accessing and copying
patient's medical records the practical
effect of that is that you should be
able to obtain your medical records
without any payment there is available
on the acquirers website guidance as to
how to go about obtaining your medical
records or those of a deceased family
member and copies of the request forms
that individuals can use we also know
that there are significant numbers of
individuals who in addition to being
able to provide their own personal
account have through years
painting and diligent research built up
a substantial amount of wider knowledge
and information the inquiry team is keen
to work with those individuals so as to
make the best use of the information and
knowledge which they have acquired for
those who very understandably do not
feel able to provide a detailed
statement there is an additional
alternative option of providing an
account to a reporter a trained
professional who will gather together
such accounts anonymously in a report to
be presented to the chair that's the
first strand of the inquiries
investigative work so far the second
strand has been to require the provision
to the inquiry of documents of potential
relevance to the terms of reference I
propose to say a few words about the
mechanics of that process first there
are certain processes which the inquiry
has to follow if the inquiry wishes a
person to produce a document it will
send a written request it's called a
rule 9 request if that person doesn't
comply the chair can require the person
to produce any documents in their
custody or control by making an order
under section 21 of the inquiry's Act
once documents are provided to the
inquiry they will first be assessed by
the inquiry for relevance consideration
will be given by the inquiry at that
stage to whether any material which is
irrelevant such as irrelevant personal
information should be redacted a process
of categorizing and indexing documents
also has to be undertaken and I'm sure
you will appreciate that this is a
time-consuming process that has to be
carried out with care and attention to
detail documents that are assessed as
relevant will then be disclosed to core
participants and we are ready to
disclose to core participants the first
batch of 4860 for documents which is
over 39,000 pages of material they will
be disclosed to core participants via
the inquiries document management system
known as relativity the inquiry has so
far made a large
number of requests for documentation
from a range of sources I don't propose
to go through all those requests in
detail but to give you a flavor of some
of the main requests requests for
documentation have been issued to the
Department of Health and Social Care in
England we have asked amongst other
things for provision of documentation
from the HIV haemophiliac litigation the
group contaminated blood products
litigation and unredacted copies of
documents hosted on the National
Archives including those provided to the
arch inquiry and Lord Owens papers
documents provided by the Department of
Health to the penrose inquiry and other
material we have asked the scottish
government and to provide all documents
and information provided to the penrose
inquiry and all documents and
information center national records
Scotland potentially relevant to the
terms of reference similar requests have
been made to the Welsh and Northern
Irish departments we have made requests
to each of the four Blood Services and
have received a very significant volume
of material from NHS Beatty in England
and the Scottish national blood
transfusion service requests have gone
to all the health trusts and boards
across the United Kingdom which are
responsible for each of the haemophilia
centres and we are starting to receive
documentation from them we've received a
schedule of information held by the
haemophilia society and we await
provision of those documents in terms of
the Trust's and schemes we've requested
the provision of information and
documents from the chief executive of
the McFarland trust and the directors of
the other Alliance house organisations
and we'll be arranging for the
inspection of material which we know
they hold
we have sent requests for disclosure and
information to five of the large
pharmaceutical companies and to the
medicines and health care regulatory
agency from the police we have received
documents relating to to criminal
investigations in Scotland arising out
of the treatment of hemophiliacs with
blood products we have sought
information from the press
and probation service about material
relating to blood donations by prisoners
in the United Kingdom the UK hcdo has
given the enquiry unrestricted access to
all of its material physical and
electronic there is a huge repository of
material there that we have begun to
search through indeed there are
repositories of vast amounts of
documentation in various physical and
electronic locations by way of example
of scale NHS Beatty holds some 90,000
boxes of materials many of those will
not be relevant to the work of the
inquiry but you will understand that it
will take us a considerable amount of
time and work to identify analyze and
share the material that is relevant so
far we received about a hundred thousand
documents we expect to receive and to
have to analyze many more times that
number in a letter to the public earlier
this year the chair said but inquiries
go through a number of phases some of
which are highly visible to the public
such as hearing evidence from witnesses
or indeed these preliminary hearings
some of which are less so for example
when working through documentary
evidence the chair observed in that
letter that it may seem as if nothing is
happening but be assured a huge amount
of work will be performed if the inquiry
is to report within a reasonable time
time spent in preparation is critical
those observations apply with particular
force at the present time over the
coming months it may seem to you that
little is happening but we can give our
insurance but a huge amount of work will
be being undertaken finally on the issue
of disclosure of documents earlier this
month the chair made a statement on
disclosure which is I think important
and worth repeating now in that
statement the chair reminded all
relevant organisations of the commitment
made by the government to produce
relevant papers the Minister for the
Cabinet Office having for informed
Parliament that the Prime Minister had
made it clear that the Department of
Health and Social Care the National
Health Services and all branches of
government should provide for
cooperation the chair emphasized in his
statement the expectation the inquiry
has that it will receive the highest
level of cooperation from all
organisations in responding to requests
for documentation and information and
the chair also explained his expectation
that all those providing documents and
information give careful consideration
to waiving legal professional privilege
rather than relying on legal
professional privilege to justify
withholding material from the inquiry
the next part of the inquiries work to
date has been to gather together the
beginnings of the expert groups the
inquiry recognizes the importance of
independent expert evidence it is keen
to ensure that all expertise provided to
the inquiry is transparent and subject
to scrutiny and is in the process of
establishing a series of expert groups
comprising individuals with recognised
experience in the relevant fields of
expertise we are not aware of this being
a course that's been taken in other
public inquiries this will we believe be
a first for this inquiry the purpose of
that expert evidence will be to inform
and support the inquiries work to ensure
that the chairs factual conclusions are
soundly based and that any
recommendations which he makes are
supported by the weight of the best
expert opinion five broad areas of
expertise have been identified thus far
firstly public health and administration
secondly medical ethics thirdly
psychosocial fourthly statistical and
fifthly clinical and that will cover
clinical specialisms of hematology
transfusion medicine hepatology and
virology in terms of process we will be
inviting
participants to identify broad issues
for consideration by the expert groups
we will publish the letters of
instruction that we send to the experts
we will share the reports that are
produced by the experts with core
participants and we will publish them on
the inquiries website so that all can
read their contents
we will also afford the opportunity for
core participants to pose additional
questions to the expert groups if there
are differences of view or emphasis
amongst members of the group on issues
relevant to the inquiries terms of
reference or where we judge that it will
be beneficial or important for expert
views to be explored at the hearings the
experts will be invited to give oral
evidence the enquiry published on its
website its new website on Friday
information about some of the experts
being approached so far before I list
those experts for the benefit benefit of
those who have not already seen what's
on the website I should make it clear
that the membership of the expert groups
has not been finally determined because
we would like to hear from core
participants any suggestions they might
have we welcome further suggestions from
core participants or indeed from others
of experts for these groups or if there
are additional areas of expertise which
you consider would assist the inquiry
the current members of the groups
identified so far some of whom I know
are in attendance today our response in
the field of medical ethics Richard
Ashcroft professor of biomedical ethics
at Queen Mary University Emma cave
professor of health care law at Durham
University
Melanie Kazarian lecturer in law at the
University of Southampton Sir Ian
Kennedy QC founder of the Center for
medical law and ethics and Julian 7sq
director of Oxford Centre for practical
ethics in the field of public health and
administration David Armstrong professor
of medicine and sociology at King
College London Mary Dixon woods
professor of healthcare improvement
studies at the University of Cambridge
and Marie Farrell professor and chair of
Health thought and society at Latrobe
Law School in Australia
Charles Vincent professor of psychology
at Oxford University and Karen Walsh
professor of Health Policy and
management at Manchester Business School
in the field of psychosocial impact the
experts identified so far Adam Leslie
Fallowfield professor of psycho oncology
at Brighton and Sussex Medical School
and Dame Therese Amato director of the
behavior and Health Research Unit at the
University of Cambridge statistics is
the next expert area and they're the
members of the group identified so far
as Sheila Byrd honorary professor
University of Edinburgh penny Chan who
was scientific coordinator of the
Canadian creaver inquiry Daniela De
Angelis therapy - director of the
Medical Research Council bio statics
unit at the University of Cambridge
Crystal Donnelly professor of applied
statistics at Oxford University and
statistical epidemiology at Imperial
College Stephen Evans professor of
former pharmaco epidemiology at the
London School of Hygiene and Tropical
Medicine Nicholas Steele professor of
biostatistics and epidemiology at the
London School of Hygiene and Tropical
Medicine
Grahame medley professor of infectious
disease modeling and director of the
center of mathematical modeling of
infectious disease at the London School
of Hygiene and Tropical Medicine and Sir
David Spiegel halter president of the
Royal statistical Society the clinical
groups at the moment less fully
populated the inquiry has sought
recommendations from a number of the
Royal Colleges and who share those
recommendations in due course with core
participants but the experts who have so
far agreed to joy the clinical group a
Jane Anderson chair of the National AIDS
trust and a Past Chair of the British
HIV Association Claire darada former
chair of the Royal College of General
Practitioners and David Gong
burg consultant clinical epidemiologists
and health protection Scotland it will I
hope be apparent from that list of those
who have been invited invited to join
the expert groups that they are leaders
in their field they are all willing to
facilitate the work of the inquiry and
know that what is expected of them is
the expression of their own independent
views we look forward to receiving
suggestions from core participants of
others of additional expertise and I
should emphasize that no one should feel
under any pressure to identify experts
during the course of this preliminary
hearing they are welcome to provide
their suggestions to the inquiry over
the coming weeks I turn next to consider
the questions of involvement and
engagement more generally in line with
the chairs commitment to transparency
and accessibility people will be able to
follow the inquiries work in a number of
ways the inquiry website will be a
source of information throughout the
inquiry people can watch hearings live
at their convenience read transcripts of
all the hearings read witness statements
and expert reports check the inquiries
statements of approach which explains
its ways of working and check
practicalities important practicalities
such as how to claim expenses the
inquiry team knows that not everyone
likes websites and so they are also
communicating with people by email phone
letter and in person over the summer the
enquiry team held a number of engagement
meetings in Belfast Birmingham Bristol
Cardiff Glasgow Leeds Liverpool
Manchester Newcastle and London so that
people could hear about the terms of
reference and the plans for these
hearings and talk about the work of the
inquiry the enquiry team will be
returning to these cities throughout the
inquiry so the people can meet and ask
questions of the inquiry team I turn
next to the likely organisation of the
hearings that will commence in due
course we know that many people have
been anxious to know the time scale for
the inquiries work
there are two particularly important
factors that are at the forefront of the
inquiries planning in this regard
firstly we know that even in the time
since a public inquiry was announced a
number of those infected have died we
know and I can assure you that this is
something which the enquiry team is
acutely conscious of but more will die
before the enquiry ends we understand
therefore that it is important for the
inquiry to undertake its work as quickly
as possible
secondly however we know because this is
what you have told us that many of you
consider this to be the last chance to
get the answers which you have sought
for so long and that the inquiry must
therefore be fairer and vigorous as the
chair has said therefore the inquiries
work will be completed as quickly as a
reasonable fairness permits we are able
to give our intended start date for the
inquiries main public hearings the
inquiry intends to start hearing the
evidence from the 30th of April 2019
once if against the inquiry proposes to
sit for three weeks out of fall and for
up to four days per week the structure
of the hearings and this is our
provisional thinking only will be as
follows we propose as the chair has said
to start by hearing evidence from a
range of infected and affected people
the inquiry wants to hear at firsthand
the accounts and experiences of those
infected and affected covering groups
across the UK that evidence will be
heard in London in Edinburgh in Belfast
in Cardiff and probably in Leeds we
anticipate that this part of the
inquiries evidence will be heard over
the three-month period in May June and
July next year the next part of the
inquiries hearings will in all
likelihood
start again from the beginning of
October of next year the inquiries
current thinking is that it will at this
point start hearing evidence about the
key issue set out in the first part of
its terms of reference namely what
happened and why it's this part of the
inquiry hearings that will look at what
was known or ought to have been known
about the risks of infection by
government pharmaceutical companies
licensing authorities NHS bodies the
medical profession than others it's this
part of the inquiries hearings that will
examine how it was that people with
haemophilia were given infected blood
products and people requiring
transfusion were given infective loved
this part of the inquiries hearings will
look at the adequacy of the systems in
place the questions of self-sufficiency
in England Wales Scotland and Northern
Ireland and we'll also hope in that part
of the inquiry to look at the likely
numbers infected and the risks of
exposure to other diseases we cannot say
at this stage precisely how long that
part of the inquiry hearings will last
but we anticipate that it is likely to
be in the region of something like five
months worth of hearings the third part
of the hearings again this is all
provisional is to look at treatment care
and support including financial support
and the many concerns that have been
expressed about the Trust's and schemes
the differences in financial assistance
and the justification or absence of
justification for those differences we
were then proposed to sit to hear issues
relating to consent communication and
information sharing those key ethical
issues that are still highly relevant to
modern-day medical practice we would
then propose to look at the response of
government and other bodies and to
examine forensic Lee the issues of KUB
and lack of candor the penultimate part
of the inquiries evidence hearings would
be to consider recommendations for the
future and to hear evidence related to
that and then the last part of the
inquiries evidence to be heard would be
as the chair has said further accounts
from those infected and affected however
I emphasize that this plan in particular
the sequencing and organization of
issues after the first three months is
very Provost though it is dependent upon
two factors in particular firstly the
views of core participants and others
with an interest in the inquiry as to
how the inquiry should structure the
hearings you may tell us that you think
there are better ways of organizing and
structuring and listening to the
evidence secondly it's dependent upon
the volume of material that we receive
both in terms of documents and witness
statements all of which will require to
be processed analyzed and where relevant
disclosed to core participants
sufficiently in advance of any hearings
to enable adequate time for
consideration it may be that in light of
those matters we will have to make
adjustments to this provisional
timetable and in particular to the order
in which we consider particular aspects
of the terms of reference we are not at
present able to give a reliable estimate
as to how long this process will take
because of the huge amount of material
that we are expecting to receive but our
best estimate is that once hearings
begin at the end of April next year they
will not take less than a year into
quarter one question that has been
raised by many respondents to the
consultation process and indeed was
trailed in the media yesterday is
whether the inquiry is likely to hear
from government ministers at relevant
times the answer to that question we
think is yes we will in the course of
the investigative work expect to obtain
witness State
it's from senior politicians including
successive secretaries of State for help
from senior civil servants and senior
doctors involved in policy setting and
decision-making we enter anticipate that
a number of such witnesses will be
expected to give oral evidence and thus
be questioned publicly for the first
time about their decisions and actions
we expect such witnesses will attempt to
give evidence without compulsion but the
inquiry has no hesitation in using the
powers conferred by the act if so
required I'd like to conclude by making
two points firstly the inquisitorial not
adversarial nature of the inquiry
process it is the inquiries job to
investigate impartially and fairly and
to report on the matters detailed in the
terms of reference the inquiry carries
out that task of investigation in all
the ways that I've been describing from
obtaining and analyzing the vast amounts
of documentation from gathering
statements from witnesses and we
anticipate we will end up with thousands
of such statements and from holding
public hearings at which key witnesses
will be questioned it is a very
different process from litigation and
the roles of those who participate
whether legally represented or not
differs from the roles of litigants from
the inquiries perspective there are no
parties sides or cases to prove but a
process of independent and forensic
investigation and examination my final
point is this we as an inquiry team are
acutely aware that lives have been
devastated and destroyed in consequence
of the use of infected blood products
and inflected blood this inquiry cannot
reverse or undo what has happened but
the inquiry team will do everything it
reasonably can
to provide the answers to the questions
that have been sought for so long and to
fulfill the inquiries terms of reference
thank you
[Applause]
well thank you ladies and gentlemen I
that brings the formal proceedings to a
close today but you are very welcome to
stay for a while and chat to each other
you may want to talk about what you have
heard you may even want to talk to some
of the enquiry team if you wish you're
welcome to do that thank you for your
attendance thank you for listening and I
look forward to seeing you and to begin
to hear what the core participants have
to say tomorrow
[Applause]
[Applause]